[Musique]
1794 si les députés français proclament
dès 1790 que tous les hommes naissent et
demeurent libre et égau en droit ce
n'est qu'en 1794 qu'ils abolissent
l'esclavage dans les colonies c'est
avant tout la conséquence de la grande
révolte des esclaves de saint-d doming
la plus grande colonie à sucre de France
confronté dans cette grande île à
l'insurrection menée par toussin
l'ouverture ainsi qu'à l'entrée en
guerre de l'Espagne et de la
Grande-Bretagne les représentants de la
France y décident sans en référer à
Paris d'abolir l'esclavage en
1793 c'est mis devant le fait accomp que
la représentation nationale vote donc
l'abolition le 4 février
1794 il faut attendre 2 ans pour que les
envoyés de la République apporent
officiellement le décret dans les
mascares arrivé à l'île-de France ils
sont remembarqué sans ménagement par les
notables Mauriciens soutenus par ceux de
Bourbon cette première abolition annulée
par Bonaparte en 1802 n'a donc jamais
été appliqué dans les
mascarines
1794 refus de l'abolition de l'esclavage
dans les
[Musique]
masquaré